alarm bells here in germany as book
talks at two university campuses were
canceled this week allegedly due to
pressure from china the online events
were to mark the publication of a new
biography xi jinping the most powerful
man in the world co-authored by two
german journalists but the publisher
told local media that the talks were
abruptly called off after chinese
interference including from the
consulate in dusseldorf
the book talks in hanover and duesberg
were initially sponsored by chinese
centers known as confucius institutes
which are affiliated with the german
campuses both university administrations
say they were not involved in the
planning of the events but are concerned
about the cancellations in a statement
the university of duisburg essen said
quote the administration is particularly
disturbed that official pressure was
apparently used to stop this event we
cannot understand this decision and it
cannot be allowed to happen again
we're joined now by one of the authors
of the book adrian gigas who joins us
from hamburg welcome to the program now
you were meant to be at both of these
book events but they were cancelled can
you tell us what happened
so a few days before the event
we got contacted by the confucius
institutes and they said oh we are very
sorry we would like to do it and we
announced it of course
but
we got an order from beijing
not to do it
and i asked why i mean this
is a book about china which tells it
from all sides it's not a china
bashing book
and they said yeah the problem is
according to their chinese counterparts
it is a book about xi jinping and they
don't want this person to be touched and
discussed and that's why they hadn't
been allowed to do it
but originally they were on board to do
the event and then they said they got a
call or some kind of contact from
beijing that said please cancel this
event
exactly so
they had been very sorry and they said
we got this pressure that even that
they got the pressure not directly from
their counterparts at the chinese
universities you know it's always a
corporation
german university and chinese university
in fact their counterparts in the
chinese universities had agreed as well
to these events but they got pressure
from the top
not to do it and that their counterpart
they are even fried frightened and even
after they explained now this is
very harmful for the confucius institute
in germany that said
we don't care this is too dangerous
right and as you said you you mentioned
that your book is looking at the
president from all sides it's not a book
that only praises him you're a little
bit critical as well do you feel that's
the reason why this event was cancelled
yeah i mean
what i'm feeling is and what they even
told us it's because you know there's
such a
cult of personality around xi jinping
now in china
and even to portray him as a human being
is too much i mean even to write
simple facts
he was divorced or something like this
we don't care about it we only mentioned
it in a sentence in the book
even this is too much because they will
uh show him in china as something like
like a superstar or even like like a god
and so to show him as a normal person
and to show the personal history of his
life is already too much for them
now in response to these cancellations
the universities themselves have
scheduled their own events about your
book without the confucius institutes
one of the events was last night why do
you think it's important that these
events take place
oh very important because i mean what it
was it was an attempt
of censorship so to censor not only in
china
itself as we know it but
to
censor also in germany and in other
countries and luckily there had been a
lot of protests in the last days a lot
of media attention
media a lot of media reported about it
and this is the reason why
because it was embarrassing for the
universities as well why the university
universities decided to hold these
events
adrian gigas the co-author of xi jinping
the most powerful man in the world thank
you very much for your time
we reached out to both confucius
institutes for comment here's how the
hanover center explained its
cancellation there were differences of
opinion with our chinese partners this
meant it was no longer possible to
retain the format and for the confucius
institute to be involved
joining me now for more is thorsten
benner he's the co-founder and director
of the global public policy institute
here in berlin thurston thanks for
taking the time let's talk a bit about
the confucius institutes here in germany
how do they operate and what kind of
links do they have to the universities
in this country
thank you for having me abby confucius
institutes are an interesting animal
because unlike for example the german
goethe institutes
they're not operating just independently
in a in the third country but we have
more than a dozen confucius institutes
that are on the one hand co-funded and
co-run by
chinese party state institutions but
they're part and affiliated and co-run
by german universities that are
committed to academic freedom and that's
just not a match
academic freedom you say academic
independence should german universities
then be linked with these institutes
no i don't think they should the
solution is actually pretty simple just
cut them loose from german german
universities and have them just operate
independently and the german government
should
invest massively in independent chinese
culture and language competence and
build that up at german universities
they're simply no match it's not for no
reason that in the academic freedom
index china ranks to the very bottom we
cannot accept
that
to have chinese funding and
institutions that are co-run
by beijing affiliated with german
universities that's simply no match it's
a massive reputational risk as we've
seen also in the recent case of these
cancer lectures where we had direct
interference from beijing on on this
and
but as i said the solution is pretty
simple and
confucius institutes are one example of
the problematic tie-ups
with the the chinese
academic system in in germany but
they're by far not the biggest challenge
i found now beijing is not timid about
calling out instances it feels is
interference by other states has
chancellor merkel and her governments or
successive governments done enough to
push back on beijing
no i think we've seen a turning of the
tide there's
there's quite a quite a few politicians
who are calling out the problems uh
involved with if you accept chinese
funding if you have confucius institutes
the risks of self-censorship of economic
espionage in academic cooperation with
beijing but the chancellor herself she
hasn't done much to the contrary earlier
this year we had a case where beijing
slapped sanctions on german independent
researchers and research institutes such
as the marcato institute for china
studies the biggest research center on
china in in europe and all we got
from the chancery was silence and that's
not acceptable
there's not i do want to ask you then
we're going to see a new coalition
government here in germany what could or
should they do differently when it comes
to beijing
i think they they should match the risks
much better and
cut any
any dependence on chinese funding in the
german academic sector german professors
shouldn't have any business taking
consulting fees and from from from china
and they should speak out for academic
freedom and
be uncompromising
uncompromising on that they should
encourage collaboration but manage the
risk much better and i do think we have
a
firm basis for that the greens and the
free democrats have spoken up very
clearly about
the risks of academic freedom not being
kind of held in high regard by beijing
and the risk of the cooperation and
there are quite a few in the in the
social democrats uh who are kind of
pushing
for this also in in merkel's party many
don't buy her a pro i i do think we're
in
we have an opportunity for change on on
on this front and restructuring the
relationship so potentially
a turning of the tide with with the new
government there thorsten banner
director of the global public policy
institute thank you for your insights
thurston